how do you avoid GPT for from being
hacked or jailbroken there's a lot of
interesting ways that people have done
that
like uh with token smuggling
or other methods like Dan
you know when I was like a a kid
basically I I got worked once on
jailbreaking an iPhone the first iPhone
I think
and
I thought it was so cool
I will say it's very strange to be on
the other side of that
you're not the man kind of sucks
um is that is some of it fun how much of
it is a security threat I mean what how
much do you have to take it seriously
how is it even possible to solve this
problem where does it rank on the set of
problems I'll just keep asking questions
prompting we want
users to have
a lot of control and get the models to
behave in the way they want
within some very broad bounds and I
think the whole reason for jailbreaking
is right now we haven't yet figured out
how to like give that to people and the
more we solve that problem I think the
less need there will be for jailbreaking
yeah it's kind of like piracy gave birth
to Spotify
people don't really jailbreak iPhones
that much anymore and it's gotten harder
for sure but also like you can just do a
lot of stuff now
just like with jailbreaking I mean
there's a lot of hilarity that is